what you want to hear a rap that
silverware killing it yeah can I just
clarify because in England silverware is
actual silver things right and we call
knives and forks cutlery are you
referring to knives and forks and spoons
right
yes core just to clarify
silverware but you know the knives and
forks thing so you guys over here what
John Rambo Titanic do you want to pick a
specific aspect of Titanic someone's
about to help you over here they're like
oh yeah what's on it
she said grounding which is what someone
who was drowning would call drowning
just they don't have their own brand
Brown thing what do you say the hot man
dying yeah you know that wasn't the
documentary right that's a film okay so
so the hot men dying in Titanic by
drowning so handsome and rounding in
Titanic that's that's pretty good at
silverware back of the room people right
at the back let's get something from you
you know you're quite far away from the
stage right so you need to be loud have
they all left what's happened
don't just shout sex out of the dark
that's when a man in a dark area of a
room shouts sex everyone gets very
worried we should probably leave a crime
is about to happen no that's boring
come on something good don't just add a
Y to it you just went sexy wait what did
you say gummy bear gummy bears I'm gonna
say I'm gonna add sexy to that sexy
gummy bears sexy gummy bears the
handsome men drown being in Titanic
silverware this side of the middle of
the room which will wrap up it's just a
realistic off perfectly timed that
lady's emphysema
as I said you can't say breaks it breaks
it's too obvious
good ventriloquism this side of the room
Barney Barney Barney the friendly
dinosaur yeah cool cool and and let's
get one final one from anyway Wow what
hamsters that's an animal that's
forbidden doughnut making thank you I
feel that the hamsters was just kind of
like rope-a-doping me just pulling me in
hey say something really simple and then
hit him with something that no one has
ever really thought about ever
okay so we have silverware handsome men
grounding in the Titanic sexy gummy
bears doughnut making and what was the
other one we had barney cool how could
we forget him this then lovely people of
the comedy and magic club little treat
to close out the night thing called a
freestyle rap that has a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions never written down never
before before and never to be seen again
and don't worry it won't be as bad as
you're expecting it to be thank you for
laughing person down here just like hah
yeah fat chance of that now let's do it
let's drop that beat let's have some fun
[Applause]
with some more juice on that as well
yeah it sounds tinny as hell can we
unten this cool sounds good yeah
Kenya with you a sound show but I was
too busy traffic right let's I'm excited
about this he goes make up around now
make up as a girl flow year I never plan
to see a handsome man Brown when he sing
the Titanic
used to have four funnels only three
words when I hit the ocean floor they
got preserved white star line sinking to
the bomb yeah Leo DiCaprio we forgot
about him he was floating but then no
more r.i.p but i know there was room on
the door rolls you should have let that
guy on all of the lifeboats they float
on who move away yeah be a stranger died
in the teet let the Lusitania or another
ship went down low he was a very nice
people fellow so many guys who died of
thirst
technically drowning went down first cuz
the children and the ladies and the
books they survived everybody else sink
no float even if you hold your breath it
gets cold and you drown here and you'll
never get old if you travel in the
passenger class that was so long and all
paper white your ask you deep down there
yeah they would harm me all along in my
favorite dinosaurs call Barney he's the
only one
purple not pink it's hurtful if you say
that Isaac's think cuz he's not TV he is
on it only dinosaur not killed by a
comet when it came down on white the
mouth he was hiding around then he
jumped out and said everybody come play
with me is the way that we share on all
of the cable all terrestrial and if you
come to my banqueting-hall you will see
so much cutlery there you will be like
this is amazing eyes windows double
glazing eat you just start grazing could
be a stranger don't go away pick up a
small salad fork for the entree then
we're gonna increase in size her who
wait which order is it is an appetite
I don't even know it's hard to talk I'm
gonna talk about the teaser for why is
it so damn small mate I want a big slice
up this nice cheesecake again
cutlery is silver-plated now you know
it's solid silver gyrated to earn all
that stuff it was fun I love it when
candy gets stuck in my gums are not you
they cast alright in my teeth if it's
horrible get my tongue whistles beneath
remove the Rakata unplug there cuz gummy
bears are full of sugar in my mouth
Christ and free these come he bears are
so sexy and teeny one gummy bear rock in
the bikini Wow science can be arouses me
anyway this is kind of funny in fact I
give you a [ __ ] that would be a
coming next in pjsait pH that's a
doughnut hole let me tell you how I make
this take all the pastry in my bakery I
take a lot of time never do it hastily
for Hollywood and then I just rolled you
turn it connected make a little hole
some people say you're gonna stamp out
with a cup I'm like now I will not
discuss my techniques for making I
cooked it in the oil
flip over about ten seconds make sure
the employers make sure you're always
really hot get in a fryer don't cook it
in the pot because you get a mad fire
when the oil it's boat yeah oh - give me
lots of donut money money I am I
Chris Turner everybody
[Applause]